ihr parteivorsitzender norbert walter
borjans hat dann am montagmorgen bei den
kollegen deutschlandfunk dann nochmal
von von voodoo ökonomie gesprochen mit
blick auf das steuerkonzept der fdp
geben also ich kann nur deutlich machen
und das habe ich sowohl im
parteivorstand also heute in der
bundestagsfraktion gesagt die zeit des
wahlkampfs ist jetzt vorbei ich fand das
völlig in ordnung dass man im wahlkampf
das habe ich ja auch manchmal gemacht
durchaus ein bisschen härter sich man
aushalten programmatik der aus den
anderen auseinandergesetzt hat aber
jetzt haben wir eine gemeinsame
verantwortung für dieses land und die
gemeinsame verantwortung der kann man
nur nachgehen wenn man auch eine
angemessene sprache übereinander findet
wir werden wenn wir zu gesprächen kommen
dann wird das so sein dass wir sehr hart
in der sache an vielen stellen
verhandeln sie haben gerade die
differenzen angesprochen und ich finde
eine harte verhandlungen gehört mit dazu
aber die frage gesagt ob man öffentlich
diesen schlagabtausch hat da bin ich
sehr klar damit muss jetzt mit wahlkampf
mit 18 uhr am wahlsonntag ist damit auch
schluss er wollte wie kann so etwas
passieren ihre vorsitzenden sind doch
profis meint norbert walter borjans sagt
die fdp muss sich fragen lassen ob sie
sich an eine partei des absturzes hängen
will und sagt dann dass die gespräche
für das nimmer der besuch war werden
moralisches recht gibt es gibt die frage
ob man sich jetzt an die cdu hälfte die
frage ist doch total berechtigt und dass
wir in der finanz- und ist irgendwie
formulierung dass man eine wahrheit ist
absturz ist das tut so als wäre der
partner den man gerade versucht zu
bezirzen so ein appendix sondern blind
abend den man eigentlich gar nicht
wirklich braucht wie na ja wir sind aber
stark zimmermann dabei wenn sie so etwas
hören wenn man sich hängt an eine partei
des absturz ist also die realität ist
doch so dass die spd gewonnen hat aber
nur knapp vor der cdu liegt dass beide
parteien die mal große stolze
volksparteien waren um die firmen 20
prozent 25
ist keine grosse partei mehr ist auch
keine volkspartei mehr sie hat 75
prozent gegen sich und da sind die
nichtwähler nicht mal mit eingerechnet
und ich glaube demut ich räume ein dass
man sprachlich abrüstet bin ich bei
ihnen dass demut auch bedeutet dass
selbst große parteien die sich immer
noch groß fühlen obwohl sie es jetzt
nicht mehr sind sich klar machen müssen
wir als cdu wir als sozialdemokraten da
ist bündnis 90 die grünen da sind die
freien demokraten und in diesem
demokratischen spektrum bewegt die uns
jetzt und deswegen wir sind die großen
und gucken mal welche kleinen ich auf
dem schoß nehmen und ihr seid die
kleinen bürger
das sollten wir jetzt mal sein lassen
und muss jetzt mal auf die inhalte
konzentrieren und deswegen sage ich ist
die cdu natürlich noch im spiel was bei
der cdu jetzt los ist kommentiere ich
nicht muss die cdu selber wissen wir
haben zwei optionen für maike und ampel
und genau darüber das werden wir jetzt
ab schichten was da jetzt passiert aber
da ist der drops noch nicht gelutscht
dann kommt noch mal dass das das branden
sozusagen verbale saskia esken entzieht
der union praktisch das moralische recht
alexander für verhandlungen und sagt es
geht eigentlich auch gar nicht dass fdp
und grünen miteinander reden was ist
denn das für ein missverständnis das
wäre unklug weil sie tun ist ja schon
also ja morgen aber da liegt natürlich
tatsächlich eine gefahr für die spd drin
die vielleicht auch im rausch des sieges
ein bisschen unterschätzt wird weil wenn
man die zehn führenden leute der fdp
anguckt die würden alle lieber mit
laschet koalieren und das kann die cdu
selber kaputt machen wenn sie den
laschet abschießt aber sonst über die
das machen wenn sie sich die zehn
führenden leute der grünen angucken das
sind leute hier am alle schon mit
schwarz grün geplant die dachten alle
das wird ein wahlkampf wo entweder
bernburg von lead oder laschet aber auf
jeden fall diese koalition die denken
auch alle dass das eigentlich das
zukunftsmodell ist und robert habeck hat
schon mal eine jamaika koalition
verhandelt in schleswig holstein und der
erste schritt dahin war genau diese
sondierung fdp grüne aber genau das da
ist das foto oder wenn wolfgang kubicki
hier von herrn huber spricht spricht da
von robert also das ist ja noch unter
riesigen grünen der der der rationalen
kern dass man sich sehr gut da gibt es
eine echte verbindung der rationalen
kern der lasche strategie ist wenn er im
spiel bleibt gibt er die der spd die
möglichkeit erst zu vermasseln also wenn
die spd zu hochfahren auftritt oder
denkt sie kann dieses alte gerhard
schröder koch und kellner spiel
betreiben und da war oder falls ja
damals dabei dann könnten die beiden
etwas kleineren parteien sagen da sind
wir vielleicht bei gleicher besser
aufgehoben das ist der rationalen kern
der strategie von laschet sich im spiel
zu halten und dann gibt es ja noch die
andere achse als gibt da ja 2 wirklich
enge verbindungen wolfgang und robert
und dann gibt es da noch arminen
christian also direkt
belastet der übergang sagte serlet
eigentlich mal entdeckt auf denen dann
am liebsten mit dem christiania also man
darf politik auch nicht jetzt als
persönliche beziehung aber war es
deswegen bei der recherche eine rolle es
gibt bei der fdp eine traumatische
erfahrung weil angela merkel und volker
kauder die 2013 versenken wollten als
die fdp raus gewählt wurden dachten die
die kommen nie wieder und da hat laschet
nicht mitgemacht hat war derjenige der
gesagt hat nein es muss eine liberale
partei geben und die müssen wir pflegen
also dass das ist wirklich in ordnung
aber wenn man auch in sozusagen mein
inhalten denkt die leute auf dem realo
flügel der grünen
die auch erfolgreich in baden
württemberg mit der cdu regieren haben
eine idee was mit diesem land passieren
könnte die er in jamaika funktioniert
die frage ist ob sie das ihrem linken
parteitag erklärt bekommt das eine
andere frage aber die idee ist erst mal
da und da wäre das einfallstor wenn herr
laschet so lange stehen bleibt doch noch
in eine echte jamaica sondierung zu
kommen herr in nrw sie als innenminister
sie kriegen das ja mit die diese
verbindung zwischen armen und christian
wie die beiden sich nutzen sich ja man
kennt sich man schätzt sich dann
vertraut sich man regiert mit einer
hauchdünnen mehrheit ziemlich
geräuschlos das funktioniert ist das die
zukunft ist dass das wovon das abhängt
ich kann dir nur aus der erfahrung
berichten eine stimme mehrheit ja nie
konflikt oder wenn dann werden sie sagt
nicht gelöst es gibt sie streit nach
draußen und das hat ganz ganz viel mit
den beiden köpfen zu tun bei uns ist
joachim stammt und armin laschet die in
einer art der der der problemlösung
organisiert haben die ich noch nie in
meinem leben erlebt habe ich habe in
unterschiedlichen gremien gearbeitet ich
kann ihnen sagen ich habe mir das lange
überlegt damals ging ich nach düsseldorf
im europaparlament und ich bereue es
keine sekunde das ist eine ganz
attraktive interessante form von
sachlicher problemlösung da wird
gerungen wer nötig und das war es
erledigt werden kann wird schnell
erledigt vier jahre wir haben da glaube
ich also ich kenne keinen der sagt
werden schlecht gearbeitet opposition
muss ja schimpfen aber so von der
berichterstattung habe ich das noch
nirgendwo gelesen dass da irgendwie
großen fehler passieren und das hat viel
zu tun mit der art und weise wie man
probleme angeht und mein eindruck ist
dass die bürger und bürger diese
billigen streitereien oder wer hat zu
sagen wer ist zweiter sowieso sind die
leute sagen wir haben eine wahnsinnig
schwierige zeit das fühlen ja alle und
wir brauchen menschen die die probleme
lösen und deswegen bin ich da ganz
gelegen im moment mal das wahlergebnis
war nicht relax und das war ärgerlich
und verhandeln sie das bitte natürlich
ist fürchterlich ärgerlich sie haben ist
katastrophal genannt jetzt haben sie es
nur noch ärgerlich
ich habe da mit dem anderen wahlergebnis
gerechnet gehofft und als wir am anfang
runtergehen und dann die letzten wochen
wieder hoch kriegt dann hat man gedacht
ja gott vielleicht packen was doch noch
also da kann ja keinen freund lange
herum zu diskutieren nur eins ist
interessant der abstand ist so dass im
grunde keiner von den beiden großen
parteien als vorschlag ein zimmermann
natürlich total recht sagen kann wir
sind die großen helden 5 und wir haben
beide 75 prozent der menschen die uns
nicht gewählt haben beide und das ist
eigentlich die frage die uns als cdu da
mal beschäftigen muss wieso ist das so
gekommen ist dass plötzlich passiert nur
wegen des wahlkampfs für jeden ihrer
wahl herein wie geht in ihrer erklärung
ich habe menschen anzahl hat armin
laschet daran ich habe keine einfache
erklärung weil ich bin ich bin jetzt so
lange dabei ich habe das so oft gehört
wie man immer so schnell satz ab erklärt
warum eine wahl verloren gegangen ist
ist leider komplizierter es hat mehrere
faktoren das eine ist ein langfristig
glaube dass die cdu in der art wie
mitglieder sich entwickelt haben wie
politische arbeit in der cdu war über
viele jahre schon in einer art
entwickelt haben wenig preisverdächtig
war aber wir haben die kanzler gestellt
und deswegen war bevor und die spd sind
das heißt dass sie waren bequem sie
waren ja ganz mehr so lebendig lebendig
so engagiert zu diskussionsfreudig alles
so was fällt mir dazu ein und die spd
hat sich zerstritten und damit war das
leben relativ einfach und wir gewannen
ja auch immer fröhlich so und ich glaube
also einfach und dass er besser als ich
ganz schlecht da gab es ein paar bei uns
gedacht wir würden also versuch mit
streiten haben wir ja schön beschrieben
das ergebnis ist jetzt zu besichtigen so
und jetzt muss man einfach drüber
nachdenken erstens im grunde drei
aufträge erstes was lehrt uns das für
die 10 uhr selber für unsere partei wir
werden nachdenken müssen was verändern
müssen zweitens wir gewinnen aber nicht
warten bis wir damit fertig sind sondern
wir haben jetzt auch ein wähler auftrag
wir haben ja immer ein knappe 25 prozent
die sagen ihr sollt regierung also wir
haben schon auftrag uns auch darum zu
kümmern und drittens das ist das
allerwichtigste dass haben aber im
grunde alle gesagt die frage ist nur was
jeder darunter versteht den auftrag
dafür zu sorgen dass diesem land
vernünftig regiert wird so und was
vernünftig ist da unterscheiden und 7
und ich glaube übrigens dass die
wortmeldung von ascon und von kühner zur
fdp nicht nur eine woche entlassung sind
sondern es hat etwas zu tun mit der
einschätzung ich glaube dass die
wirtschaftspolitik aller fdp genauso
einschätzen das ist ein qualitativer
unterschied
das sagen haben ja in den letzten wochen
niemals gesagt
okay sie sind jetzt gerade wieder beim
versuch frau stark zimmermann das
kärtchen mit würdest du mit mir gehen ja
nein vielleicht macht das netz damit
sind nicht alle brauchen also ich bin
hier klicken der herr mützenich sitzt
tief nach meiner herr mit sind nicht
heute der sitzt tief er sitzt nicht tief
sondern ich weiß gott nicht wird gerne
was sagen zum regieren aber
das muss man jetzt auch nicht eine
stunde darüber diskutieren ob peking bei
sie haben es ja gerade gesagt die
tonalität macht schon die musik und ich
glaube in der situation eine bestimmte
höflichkeit eine kritische höflichkeit
ist schon angesagt und deswegen wir sind
alle erwachsen
erwarte ich eine andere tonalität von
ihrem fraktionsvorsitzenden wenn wir
überhaupt zusammen an den tisch treten
sollten aber fraktion man das was nützt
sie nicht gesagt hat war dass dieses
jamaika bilder verheerend war und das
ist doch so dass diese da streitet doch
auch in der fdp niemand ernsthaft ab
dass diese bilder wie die jungs da rauch
und auf dem balkon stehen dass das ganz
viele nach nahrung wir hatten gedacht
die kleinen sollen sich nicht so
aufplustern
und gemeint war warum verhandeln die
überhaupt die sonne doch bitteschön
zugehört in dem interview hatte mundt
deutschlandfunk wir können das jetzt
gern irgendwie nochmal nachhören hat er
ganz klar gesagt es ist völlig in
ordnung dass die miteinander reden da
gibt es differenzen die müssten
ausgeräumt werden das ist doch gut wenn
man miteinander spricht herr schuldig so
ich wollte eigentlich was sagen so im
regierungsauftrag wenn ich darf ja
dürfen sie sofort aber lasst uns auch
gleich noch mal eine analyse der cdu
machen sich regierung ist mein berater
ins interessant weil ich interessant
finde wenn er sich jenseits und sagt bei
25 prozent und damit bei den
regierungsauftrag und ich meine man muss
auch schon ob wir mal sehen welche also
die spd ist auf platz drei der branche
spd samstagsschichten sein weil die
meisten stimmen sie sind ja in dieses
rennen gestartet und auch gesehen dass
sie haben dann schlagen sie haben sich
ja nur noch mit aber wir haben auch
einige apps erhalten elisa bestimmtes
interesse und haben gedacht die cdu
damit die cdu sich an regierung
beteiligt wir haben nicht gesagt gar nix
braucht die spd ist auf platz drei
gestartet die union als armin laschet
cdu vorsitzender wurde lag die union
fast 40 prozent in den umfragen gut aber
das schon mal ein nein man muss sich
einmal angucken wo der balken der union
hingegen dass da jetzt sich jemand
hinstellt und wie herr laschet und sagt
wir haben den klaren auftrag eine
regierung zu führen aber das hat das hat
er nicht gesagt wird später seine
nächsten tag so her weil ich bin genau
zugehört
hat gerade den seligen beim alten
trikots auf wie sein für uns in diesen
jahren gerade gesagt sein land aber sie
vor und sind also wissen sie man sich
ganz leichten darf ich kurz einmal ins
leben als ich das war derselbe ein
generalsekretär wurde hat
sicherheitsmesse schon viele analyse
gemacht habe ich in auftrag gegeben habe
ich mal unabhängig fünf experten darauf
gucken lassen was wir eigentlich falsch
gemacht haben aber das erlebe ich gerade
nicht belastet aber nur noch mal auf die
agenda
das nachlesen was sagen sie lebt die
legende mit dem regierungsauftrag
laschet hat unter riesigen beifall da
immerhin auch der mir persönlich auch
ein bisschen laut war das war aller
ergeben so weit gesagt wenn wir haben
einen auftrag unserer näheren wehland
genau ein linksbündnis so und das ist
doch eigentlich genau das ist leider
genau und das ist doch eigentlich genau
das gleiche wie letzte mal aber letzte
mal hatte die cdu gewonnen und hat
versucht jamaika zu machen und als das
nicht klappte musste die spd ein
springen sie musste von ihrem eigenen
bundespräsidenten gezwungen werden aber
sie hat es verdienstvoller weise getan
so jetzt verhandelt olaf scholz seine
ampel und wenn das nicht klappt muss die
cdu selbstverständlich bereit schiffe
jamaika ich mal dafür haben wir doch
parteien und in diesen gedanken wollte
laschet ein bisschen 40 rüberbringen
aber das ist ja mehrere leute um armin
laschet zu erklären dass er das wirklich
gesagt aber dafür haben sich als
journalist dass ich immer erkläre was
ich meine und ich habe nur darauf
hingewiesen dass herr all gerade genau
den gleichen terminus benutzt hat er
nämlich auch gesagt wir haben von
unseren wählern einen regierungsauftrag
bekommt ist ja ganz interessant in
diesen zeiten wirklich auf die
einzelheiten zu hören weil das ist
gerade die zusagen die nebelkerze gerade
geworfene herold nochmal mit ihrer
analyse wenn sie sagen wir können so
nicht weitermachen das ist so ein
schöner satz ist aber in wahrheit auch
eine eine bin sind es ist eine frage was
was doch was heißt das denn er besitzt
das ist die konsequenz daraus
hat der armin laschet hat
generalsekretär im bundesvorstand schon
angekündigt dass wir jetzt erster
fehleranalyse machen zweitens mit der
partei reden also muss debattenkultur
entwickelt werden über die frage wir
müssen darüber reden und auch lösungen
finden was wir in zukunft ändern aber
das können sie nicht mal so eben aus im
moment machen sondern das ist eine
relativ schwierige aufgabe das machen
sie parallel die subventions vergangen
ja ich glaube es muss so gemacht werden
weil wir können ja nicht warten bis wir
damit fertig sind dann bei anderen
parallel verhandelte sichere also leider
sind hier drei aufträge zu erledigen
müssen parallel erledigt werden so ist
das und ich kann uns nur raten nicht das
eine gegen das andere auszuspielen
sondern alle aufgaben müssen erfüllt
werden was was was ist mit verantwortung
die man irgendwann übernimmt wenn man
für so ein katastrophales wahlergebnis
deutlich ist wieso ist das so außer mode
gekommen zu sagen ich übernehme
verantwortung
das heißt verantwortung übernehmen das
heißt das würde heißen ich räume den
platz und dass er sich dieser
verantwortung nicht die einzige
konsequenz die ich übernehme
verantwortung hat der armin laschet in
allen gremien bin ich dabei war erzählt
er hat auch vorgetragen dass auch er
fehler dazu beigetragen hat von
vornherein aktion heute bei den
abgeordneten überhaupt
für seine fehler also ich ok man kann
sagen unternehmen sagen man kann um
entschuldigung bitten aber die frage ist
was ist die konsequenz dass man sich
jetzt darum kümmert dass ihr laden nicht
auseinanderfliegt ich finde es
verantwortungslos wenn er jetzt
hinschmeißen würde und bei uns bricht
das chaos aus dann würden wir wieder in
der partei irgendein problem lösen noch
den auftrag unserer wähler wahrnehmen
noch einen beitrag leisten eine kluge
und so können sich diese frage werde ich
aus jedem gespräch heraus sie haben eben
zu recht gesagt olafsson sie waren das
olaf scholz hat den im amt da fröhlich
gewartet nachgedacht ob nicht zerlegen
die jugendlichen untereinander ja ich
kann nur sagen der armin laschet hatte
eine schwierige aufgabe er selber leidet
darunter sehr glaube ich das ja alles
andere als angenehm so ein ergebnis was
in den letzten wochen erlebt hat war
auch nicht nur preisverdächtig ja das
muss man sagen dass da waren auch sachen
dabei die waren unter der gürtellinie
alles ertragen trotzdem und gesagt ich
trage auch eine teilverantwortung aber
ich übernehmen wir jetzt auch
verantwortung kümmere mich darum wie wir
das lösen ich finde es unanständig und
so kenne ich den auch so ist er eben
noch mal es ist kein schnellschuss
mensch wieder so rum noch so rum sondern
als sehr nachdenklicher mensch der sich
darum bemüht jetzt aufgaben mit zu lösen
und ich glaube dass wir in deutschland
ist ja alles hier paar mal gesagt worden
riesige aufgaben haben
ganz schwierige probleme zu lösen haben
und da für sich zu entscheiden mit
welchem konzept man das in zukunft
besser macht es lohnt darüber etwas mehr
zu streiten als über die frage wer wann
gelegt das ist doch der punkt aber wenn
man doch die ganze zeit diese
personaldebatte hat wenn die eigenen
leute den eigenen vorsitzenden die ganze
zeit in frage stellen wie sehr kann man
sich dann ernsthaft um die zukunft
bemühen sie sehen es ja heute hat er die
erste frage einigermaßen hingekriegt
naja zumindest
kein problem auch wenn die auswahl dem
lama als tragen ist eine aufgabe ist cdu
csu zusammen zu halten und nicht
auseinander zu fallen dann ist das eine
super leistung hat die normalerweise
hätte der heute fraktionsvorsitzender
sein müssen und hätte gesagt so ich
stehe zur verfügung wenn die ampel nicht
klappt dann verhandelt ich schalker und
das hat er nicht geschafft das ist
jemand anders fraktionsvorsitzender
geworden und nur für ein halbes jahr und
alle konflikte in der union sind vertagt
und ich finde es richtig dass er dabei
bleibt weil
solange er im raum bleibt bleibt jamaika
im raum und dann hat frau
strack-zimmermann etwas mehr
verhandlungspause gegenüber herrn
klingbeil das ist sehr segensreich aber
dass die erneuerung daten sie doch mit
ja ich habs jetzt
das heißt ich habe doch nicht behauptet
dass gegeben dass wir im moment machen
schon die erneuerung geschlossen oder
fertig ist er kommt nicht beschäftigen
und muss mich damit er den ganzen tag
herum schlagen für die welt also als
frau merkel weg war also erst mal war es
ja schwierig frau merkel vom
parteivorsitz zu erlösen da wurde ja
schon an ihrem gebröckelt dann gab es
frau kramp karrenbauer gegen herrn merz
dann gab das lasche gegen herrn merz
dann gab es märz gegen söder jetzt gibt
es
laschet gegenwert gegen sparen gegen
röttgen kein paar mehr namen auf die
insel ich habe immer was zu schreiben
aber irgendwann müsste die union sich
schon mal für ein angebot einigen was
man das in der partei in dem man
demokratisch entscheidet oder über das
sich entscheiden was er 2018 demokraten
wir im parteivorsitz ja da haben sie
recht aber sie sehen dass das alleine
mal musste aber irgendwie mal
entscheiden auch noch nicht die lösung
ist aber der größe noch nie da war dass
die kanzlerin den parteivorsitz
abgegeben hat damit und dann begannen
sagte verloren oder nach der hessen- und
da geben allerdings zu dass das ein
thema ist was länger vorbei ist und was
jetzt man kann ja auch durch man kann ja
wenn man andere parteien beobachtet und
sieht dann kam eigentlich der große
risse oder wann war dann gegen
eigentlich fing das chaos an und das hat
man schon fest machen als die kanzlerin
im grunde genommen nicht mehr teil
emotional der partei war und dann das
ringelreihen begann und das haben wir
haben das ja auch mit interesse
beobachtet wer wird jetzt chef er ist
chefin hier geht man mit frau kramp
karrenbauer um und ich glaube dass das
auch menschen die nicht parteipolitisch
orientiert sind sondern politische
lösungen wollen das nicht goutieren wenn
eine solche wenn so eine wie west manier
plötzlich kommen wie sie gerade
beschrieben haben und das war schon auch
ein jahr lang der wird vorsitzender
erwerben das ist so gefährlich wie das
interessante ist sie sagen wir müssen
die konsequenzen ziehen wir haben heute
schon den ersten teil geschafft aber in
wahrheit geht es darin um personal es
geht den wartung nackten machterhalt
mich wird ehrlich interessiert und das
ist glaube ich das gefühl dass viele
wähler haben
die frage der inhalte der inhaltlichen
erneuerung sie erinnern sich an diese
fatale szene in der ihr spitzenkandidat
gefragt wird was die ersten drei dinge
sind von einer kollegin vom focus was
die ersten drei dinge sind die er sofort
erledigen würde und ich will gerne zu
gestehen es ist ein langer tag man ist
müde man hetzt durch die straßen
verstehe ich alles aber denn zwei dinge
und das dritte feld schon nicht mehr
einig ich frage mich und das ist etwas
was ich häufig hier auch in runden
erlebt habe ihre eigenen leute wissen
nicht wirklich wussten bis zum schluss
nicht wirklich wofür ihr kandidat
eigentlich wirklich steht ich glaube
nicht dass das eine frage ist die daran
festzumachen ist wofür der kandidat
steht also wer den kandidaten mir glaube
ich nicht der kandidat in nordrhein
westfalen hat eine klare position gehabt
hat die kennt jeder da weiß jeder was
für für politik machen und dies auch mit
klaren positionen inhaltlich beschrieben
in nrw wollen in nrw sind einige dieser
klaren position
ich rede immer von der bundesebene
das hat doch die spd meisterlich gemacht
ich wusste immer her schon seit langer
zeit weil sie seitdem ist das buch
hoffnungs land von olaf scholz gibt weiß
ich da will einer 12 euro mindestlohn
kann man doof finden oder nicht aber ist
mal eine klare ansage
bei ihnen weiß ich das bis heute nicht
ich habe gehört du irgendwas von
entfesselung dachte okay
entfesselungskünstler wird man im
programm beschlossen mit steuersenkungen
laschet hat sich ins vertrauen gesetzt
gesagt steuersenkungen stehen da gar
nicht hin zum laschet auf dem parteitag
gesagt ich höre man muss polarisieren
muss man nicht und im werk avatar
polarisiert und da könnte man doch
durchgehend also deshalb hat das doch
damals bei ihnen in einer wg klappt dann
hast du einen bund hat das nicht
geklappt
naja also was geklappt und nicht
geklappt hat werden wir uns sicherlich
in ruhe angucken ich glaube es hat ganz
viel damit zu tun dass eben schon mal
von vorschlag zimmermann auch
vorgetragen von ist wenn eine partei in
der öffentlichkeit wahrgenommen wird als
eine als eine politische bewegung die
nicht klar erkennen lässt dass sie zu
einer sache und zu einer person steht
wenn die leute den eindruck haben sie
vertrauen sich untereinander nicht und
da gibt es eine vorgeschichte ich glaube
ich auch sie haben recht das ist nicht
jetzt entstanden das ist ein längerer
prozess dann werden die leute diese
partei nicht wählte weiß ich auch können
sich jeder kommunalpolitischen
entscheidungen anhalte herold mir jetzt
noch mal um halte also es gab
situationen in diesem wahlkampf auch im
industriellen dann sagt armin laschet
auf dem klimawandel angesprochen das
wissen wir seit den 90er jahren dass da
was passiert
fragt man sich wo war der in den
achtzigern ich habe sie wollten mehr
geld in den 70ern kennen sie heuer von
ditfurth
kennen sie noch
entfernt wer hat damals in mitte der
70er jahre eine eine rechnung aufgemacht
ausgerechnet in eurem zdf was mit dem
klima passiert wenn wir mit dem co2
ausstoß genauso weitermachen das war in
den 70er
dann sagt man da gibt es diese jungen
leute die seit ein paar monaten auf der
straße sind verstehen sie warum junge
leute allein ich kenne aus dieser
sendung user neubauer seit mittlerweile
drei oder vier jahren
also das heißt da ist offensichtlich
sind die themen einfach nicht auf dem
radar das ist das was uns auch themen
daran diese junge leute fühlen sich
nicht wahrgenommen ist doch kein zufall
dass die jungen wählerinnen und wähler
vor allen dingen bei frau strack
zimmermann bei der fdp und bei den
grünen gelandet sind erst wähler
populärste partei die fdp und 8 bis 25
die grünen und die fdp aber das heißt
dass uns zu fall was sagt ihnen das ist
nicht zufall sondern es hat etwas zu tun
mit den inhalten die angebote ministry
total oder das meine ich doch ja aber es
gibt auch inhalte die wir angeboten
haben die nicht transportiert wurden
also nicht weil sie nicht transportiert
worden sondern weil da kein markt für da
war ich kann mich erinnern dass sie ja
wir haben schon die themen innere
sicherheit mehrfach bemüht sie sind aber
nie durchgeschlagen bei den fernseh
diskussion gab es das thema innere und
äußere sicherheit überhaupt nicht das
waren aber starke dem von uns also es
gibt auch entwicklung sind komisch aber
sie sind so und müssen wir zur kenntnis
nehmen aber muss nicht lang sein und man
muss doch themen setzt man muss doch
spüren ein verschlagen wo hin wohin die
reise geht nein ich versuche gerade zu
erklären dann selber schwer schuldig
weil ich glaube es hat sehr viel damit
zu tun nicht nur eigene themen zu haben
sie aufzuschreiben und sie vorzutragen
sondern sie müssen auch durchdringen
können und wenn man selber ein bild
bietet wo andere themen viel relevanter
sind als armin laschet gelächelt hat er
vielleicht zwei statt drei dem gerecht
ist das war ja wochenlang viel
bedeutsamer als jeder inhalt wir haben
ja das erste mal politisch inhaltlich
diskutiert in dem ersten trailer war es
glaube ich alles um die fragen liegen
links koalition als politik gegeben
hätte wäre dieses lachen niemals so
ikonografisch geworden niemals nein ich
glaube es ist und wenn man es als
kampagne richtig abgeräumt hätte
behaupte ich wer ist niemals so wichtig
geworden das ist ja ganz schwer zu
beantworten verlieren rettung muss man
mal sagen hatte die cdu denn vorher so
viele inhalte in den letzten jahren aber
er hat doch immer die inhalte von
erklingen bald umgesetzt wenn man jetzt
die ganzen besprechungen wie war angela
merkels amtszeit dann steht da
atomausstieg homo-ehe mindestlohn und
sondern alles themen vor der spd oder
vom linken spektrum der gesellschaft nur
das hat funktioniert weil die leute
gesagt haben wir machen so eine art
gemäßigte spd politik unter
cdu-kanzlerin das läuft aber das ist der
fehler von laschet war zu dachten zu
denken er kann so weitermachen und armin
kroder toll war das zeigen an dass grant
ist er von frau merkel wie funktioniert
er bekannt hat in der gesellschaft und
sich gern an die spitze gestellt hat als
die märkte jetzt ist derzeit ja nur da
braucht man keine cdu da gewann gleich
ist mit dabei gehabt jetzt muss ich
einmal erreicht weil die frage ist doch
wie führe ich den erfolgreichen
wahlkampf und wir haben sehr früh gesagt
12 sie haben das thema zu erfahren
mindestlohn gerade angesprochen wir
haben das thema stabile renten wir
hatten das dritte thema haben mit der
frage klimaschutz und das vierte war
bezahlbares wohnen und ich würde mal
sagen ich als ich wie war das mit den
renten das ist ein dicker hund natürlich
auch noch mal die fernsicht ich sage ich
weiß jetzt habe ich einmal die halbe
kanzlerkandidat zu sagen bis 20 70 für
alle die dort geboren werden sind die
renten sich angesichts vergessen denn
mir ist jetzt gerade von target er sich
gerade um die frage wie setze ich jetzt
lieber seinem wahlkreis auch hier
wenngleich ich weiß noch als wir vor
einem jahr gesagt haben zwölf euro
mindestlohn ist eines unserer
schwerpunkte da haben mir genug leute
gesagt das ist kein thema was die leute
mobilisiert und das im letzten training
über diese frage am längsten gestritten
wurde hat damit zu tun dass die spd
konsequent ein thema ein jahr lang
durchgehalten als oder jeder wusste am
ende in diesem wahlkampf dass die spd
für 12 euro mindestlohn steht die union
hat am ende in einem völligen panik
modus jede woche zwei inhaltliche
schwerpunkte gesetzt statt mal ein
expertenteam vorgestellt mal
zukunftsteam und dann busters die sind
dann abgetaucht gewesen da sie in dieser
fehleranalyse die ich gemacht habe wo
drin stand wie man ein wahlkampf
wirklich verhunzen kann
hat nicht das gefühl wir haben uns das
ding angeguckt und haben alles richtig
gemacht und die union hat sich das ding
angeguckt und hat jeden fehler
wiederholt den man in so einem wahlkampf
machen kann aber es war man eher rollen
und da muss ich widersprechen wenn man
erst mal seine zwei drei kernthemen
gefunden hat und auch wirklich
konsequent jeden tag darüber redet dann
schafft man das auch diese themen im
laufe des wahlkampfs zu schwerpunkten zu
machen und ich war total stolz als am
herzen darauf einmal der zwölf euro
mindestlohn das thema mindestlohn thema
der große streitpunkt war da war mir
klar wir haben es geschafft zum thema zu
setzen
wir haben solche themen nicht gesetzt
herold es irgendwie nicht gelungen ich
habe mich mit jemandem aus der cdu
gesprochen er sagte wir mal ganz ehrlich
sind und selbst unsere eigenen leute
wussten nicht wofür wir eigentlich
wirklich in diesem wettkampf stehen
diese diese dieser inhaltsleerer dies da
offensichtlich gibt muss man da nicht
immer mal sagen wir sind an dem punkt
wir sind bankrott wir sind inhaltlich
bankrott und müssen uns jetzt mal
überlegen was wir eigentlich wirklich
wollen wohin die reise tatsächlich gilt
das glaube ich überhaupt nicht wenn wir
haben nur über andere themen diskutiert
man kann auch sagen wir haben unser
nicht durchdringen können einverstanden
muss man dann überlegen woran lag's ich
habe eine erklärung ich glaube wenn wir
genug ansatzpunkte für andere
berichterstattung geliefert haben darf
man sich nicht wundern dass ich mit
unseren inhalten nicht beschäftigt weil
man kommt ja gar nicht dazu aber mag
sein dass man doch anders beurteilen
kann in der außenpolitik gab es doch
genug streitpunkte in der politik in der
frage wie man mit kriminalität darum
geht in fragen wie man auch mit
finanzkriminalität umgeht da glaube ich
war doch relativ klar was wir dafür eine
auffassung wir haben das fiel mir nicht
konsequent gelöst der hansestadt streit
mein haus die botschaft wir kennen das
doch aus den wahlkampf man wiederholt
immer seine botschaft irgendwann kann
man sich selber nicht mehr hören wollen
wir sagt eigentlich muss die ganze welt
jetzt kapiert haben was man steht und
das ist aber ausgeblieben und ich glaube
wenn man heute die leute auf der straße
fragt für was steht der oder die dann
wird es bei der union schwierig weil sie
sehr vieles sehr unterschiedlich gesetzt
aber interessante ist nur eben haben wir
eine analyse gehabt das lag am
kandidaten jetzt kommen wir aus lage
nicht thema ich hab dann gab es denn
sonst ist es lag daran dass diese
parteien nicht besonders
das ist doch gemeinsam aufgeschlossen
hat das heißt also es gibt nicht in
allen das eine problem es gibt mehrere
thema warum was man nach vorne zu wenden
sie hatten sie hatten kein wahlprogramm
ihr wahlprogramm wurde improvisiert weil
sie bis in brill damit beschäftigt waren
sich gegen markus söder zu wehren und
markus söder wollte ein ganz anderes
wahlprogramm also das war hatten sie die
zeit die klingbeil genutzt hat um das
alles vorzubereiten hatte laschet gar
nicht weil ja gar nicht wussten ob der
kandidat war also sie hatten kein
durchdachtes wahlprogramm sie haben auch
nicht mal durch das grundsatzprogramm
das grundsatzprogramm der cdu ist 20
jahre alt angeht kramp karrenbauer hatte
ein neues fertig ist nicht mehr
beschlossen worden dafür war keine zeit
das ding in der hand der innkraftwerke
wehrpflicht traditioneller familie alles
anti merkel steht alles noch drin ist
das offizielle grundsatzprogramm so und
merkel ist damit durchgekommen weil sie
ist noch nicht gewählt worden weil sie
in der cdu ist sondern wir alle dachten
die macht ist als kanzlerin ganz patent
und das läuft so weiter und die inhalte
die es braucht die gibt ja schon die spd
so und armin laschet fehler war und da
hat auch so wieder einen punkt weil so
da hat ja gesagt das wird so nicht
funktionieren - ladewagen wir müssen
offensiv wir müssen eigene themen wird
so und laschet hat gedacht dann auch
durch den wahlerfolg in sachsen anhalt
wo man ja dachte man kommt damit durch
war ja auch ein erfolg er kommt damit
durch mit dem sozusagen dem fünften
merkel bundestagswahlkampf und das hat
nicht geklappt und das macht es auch
schwierig weil selbst wenn sie laschet
auswechseln und wir wissen doch alle
dass es ein paar tagen oder wochen
geschieht der nächsten sie dazu gehen
sie davon aus ja wann und gegen wen weil
was ist denn das szenario was wird denn
jetzt versuche frau strack zimmermann
kann am in rastatt noch retten nur
dieser marker koalition kann armin
laschet retten dann wird er kanzler wenn
er nicht kanzler wird dann wird es ganz
bitter für ihn